in kuwait where the economy is worsening
as a result of low oil prices and the
coronavirus pandemic
parliamentary elections still went ahead
as planned
voters masked up before casting their
ballots and said they hoped these polls
would begin to turn things around
i boycotted the past two elections this
time i thought that i should participate
because the situation is deteriorating
we need to be united
and elect reformists in the parliament
so that the situation may improve
hopefully
i hope that the kuwaiti people will
choose wisely that they will choose the
people who represent kuwait
change is a must these are the first
elections in kuwait
since its new emir took office in
september
after the death of his half-brother
with the opposition weakened in recent
years analysts say no major political
shift
is expected and with the campaign season
severely muted due to the pandemic
many believe voter turnout will be lower
this year
up for grabs are 50 seats in parliament
and among the 326 candidates
a record number of women 29 are running
we have to fight corruption by choosing
who will represent us inside the
national assembly
and be a person with conscience honesty
who loves this country and its citizens
kuwait's nearly 140 billion economy is
facing a deficit of 46 billion dollars
this year
in september it was downgraded for the
first time by moody's investors service
and just a month earlier kuwait's
finance minister warned the government
may no longer be able to pay
salaries still analysts say it's not
just the economy that will pose a
challenge to the upcoming parliament
also the lack of trust and confidence
between
people among people with the parliament
and government they need them to be more
uh
effective than than what used to be and
i think this is going to be
seen in in hopefully in the election
results
many say that no matter the results the
biggest difficulty going forward
may be how to overcome legislative
gridlock mohammed al jazeera